ein neuer wettlauf um den mond ist
entbrannt und das über 50 jahre nachdem
ein mensch zum ersten mal auf dem
erdtrabanten war die pläne für eine
rückkehr zum mond sie sind weit
fortgeschritten
im kampf um uns vieles machen was man
auf der erde nicht machen kann zum
beispiel wissenschaftliche experimente
man kann mit teleskopen bisher in den in
die tiefen des weltraums schauen die auf
der erde hat man ja immer diese
helligkeit wird gestört die
radiofrequenzen und ganz wichtig und
damit haben wir sozusagen wieder eine
situation wie vor in den 60er jahren es
geht eben auch zur demonstration
technischer überlegenheit das ist auch
mit dem ziel und jetzt will auch china
auf den mond das raumfahrtprogramm der
chinesin es läuft auf hochtouren aber
die chinesen wollen nicht nur mit
astronauten auf dem mond landen sie
wollen gleich eine ganze raumstation
errichten
nasa chef bill nelson waren im gespräch
mit bild vor der neuen konkurrenz die um
unseren trabanten entspannt ist der nasa
chef sagt es gibt ein neues rennen zum
weltraum diesmal mit china und das
chinesische weltraumprogramme dient dem
militär das neue wettrennen um unseren
erdtrabanten bereitet nation große
sorgen professor walter sieht das anders
wir brauchen damit technik gut
funktioniert immer eine konkurrenz die
beliebt nicht nur das geschäft sondern
sie technologie voran die volksrepublik
hat bereits forschungsroboter auf der
mondoberfläche gelandet und auch
erfolgreich mondgestein auf die erde
gebracht der mond ist das ideale testbed
also eine teststation wo ich alles
testen kann funktioniert alles dazu
braucht man ungefähr ein jahr zeit und
wenn man das im griff hat dann kann man
auch in die tiefen des weltraums fliegen
und das ist der eigentliche grund warum
wir zum wohl nicht um dort zu leben oder
irgendwas abgebaut abzubauen sondern als
testbed
in den 2030er jahren soll in einem
weiteren schritt eine station auf dem
mond entstehen das berichten chinesische
staatsmedien
die forschungsstation könnte gemeinsam
mit russland gebaut und betrieben werden
vor einem halben jahrhundert als die
amerikaner zum ersten mal auf dem mond
landeten titel der bild der mond ist
jetzt ein ami nun 53 jahre später lautet
die frage wird der mond ein chinese